so today I'm going to present cyar on
gpus with our RI this has been in the
works for around a year and a half and
there are many stages of this and we're
going to talk about them so this is
cated for people that use Cy learn and
people that are interested on doing the
same thing with their libraries and
their codes um this this other material
for this talk is available on my GitHub
account and the link on the bottom right
here
so let's get
started so second gpus um I've been
asked this question for the last five
years every year for yeah for a long
time and the answer has always been no
we can't do this because of the
complexity like one of psych's core
principles is that we want the code to
be easily readable for most people and
easy to hack on you could you could Fork
it you could do whatever you want with
it and adding Cuda kernels is the
opposite of that so for a long time we
have not done this because of this
complexity like even our like we have fq
like we get ass so much that we have fq
entry just for this like will you ask
GPU support and then I'll read it um no
or at least not in the near future the
main reason is that GPU support will
introduce many software dependencies and
introduce platform specific issues so um
that's a his scor s and we should update
this because it's now now time to change
but that's the reasoning and um the
answer I usually give when people ask
about Cy learning gpus is there's
another library that I also maintain
with another group of people and it's
called Scorch where if you have a p
torch module and you really want to use
cycl API you could wrap um you could use
Scorch which wraps a c torch module and
then it has the interface of cycle Lear
so you can mix and match it with um any
of the tooling around Cy learn model
it's the API I use
um before I continue how many could we
use CN here okay cool all right you're
in the right place okay
so things have changed in 2022 so last
year in version
1.2 um we added um AR Ray API supports
and this added this for one estimator
because this was experimental and like
we we want this is new ground and we
want to explore the space
um that means in 2022 we had support for
numpy and Qi so numpy always had support
for but Qi is something new um that
means we could and C only runs on Cuda
on gpus so it runs on gpus but the API
was not great and I'll talk about that
later in this talk about what the
situation with in
2022 um but things got better this year
in
2023 where we enhance our support for
API such that the AP the API for using
the enabling this iny is better we also
added p t to supp Port so now um for the
functionality that supports array
API um it's better now um you could uh
and we'll talk about the API
today so um at high Lev overview of
today's talk where first um in the first
part I'll look at the user facing API
like um if you're a user site learn how
do you enable this and what do you have
to do to get this going on your on your
machine um next um so if you're user
this is for you next I want to talk
about
the um how cyc learn what cyar have to
do to make this work because cyc learn
traditionally only works on numpy and
that means we have to transition from
numpy code to this new array Pi thing so
that there are certain challenges there
and to understand those challenges I'm
going to talk about the airpi standard
itself what it is what the vision is and
to get context of um what API and then
I'll talk about the challenges right
afterwards all the things you have to
think about if you want to do this
transition um
so C
API okay so um this is for users um so
this is the example this is a standard
cycle learn
code where you have a line scri analysis
you you could fit it on an ND array and
if you call predict on it you get an ND
ARR from very standard now the question
is where does every API come into the
mix well there's two ways to enable
it
there's
uh a goal configuration so cyar has a
gole configuration object and you could
um configure it by calling second config
um everybody have this Pat go true and
you can see here that I'm creating P
torch arrays on CPU and if I pass this
to minim scream analysis at the end you
get a py torch tensor so it's using all
the operations that py torch provides to
do this computation so that's one
way the second way is
a a contact manager so you there's also
a Contex manager you could set ARR API
to specially true in this case I'm I
place things on Cuda and so now it's
running on high torch for on Cuda and
everything's exactly the same there same
API after that and everything that comes
out of this estimator is now a Cuda
tensor it's py tensor back by Cuda
device so that's it that's all you have
to do it's just the contact
manager and why did we go down this
route well this is a slide as a keynote
um this is it's it's Bas it's bench
marking the Cod we we were looking at
before
and um the blue blue the blue graph the
blue bar graph is numai it takes that
amount of time and when running on even
P TCH on CPU is faster than nump because
the operations in P torch are parallel
by default so even though you're running
on you're taking even though you're
running on CPU you're you're gaining the
benefits of how py Tor implemented
operations and they they're faster
because they're paralyzed and they they
have cd support and they have open MP so
they do a lot of operations on the CPU
code um also on on GPU you could at the
GB code that I we saw before it's also
faster on a GPU like much faster so
that's um why one of the reasons why we
wanted to try this out because there's P
Hardware um on the machines and you want
to take advantage of it and this is one
way to do it um we I ran this on a 16
cor machine and on RTX 390 so it's for
these
benchmarks so that is the API that's all
you have to do like as a user this all
you have to think about either do a
global configuration or cont manager so
if you're user that's it it's that's the
API now the support is very incremental
because we wanted to make sure that this
is what the direction we want to go to
so in 1 point3 we only have one thing
supporting this
um but this this has been gain traction
over the like the last six months where
in the 90 bu we have it's it's growing
the do is growing and when we release T
1.4 um there support from more things so
um and it's it's slowly growing and and
we have community members that um
enabled High Tor support for MPS like if
you have a Mac machine now you have NPS
devices and it's it's all going it's
it's going there it's getting there so
this is the the r support um you could
look at the documentation here on the
bottom and so to list out all the things
as
importance so that's the cyc
API now I want I want to talk now I want
to switch gears or like who who here
writes array code like they use NP or Pi
torch in the dayto day like somehow yeah
okay so this is Rel to you like the you
you you you write array code um and um
there's um something called the array
standard which I'm going to get into
and the vision of array API was that
there are many array libraries
there's there's there's a subset of them
here and they all have an
API it's not a standard like um Q match
almost wor like it's almost matching but
p and nump the AP are similar but not
exactly the same because if you want to
migrate code from P to nump you have to
or nump to P you have to know the
intricacies the py T and um know know
that yes the vision
of uh of the array Pi
standard um which is built by the this
Consortium um of it's called the consum
for python dat standards and it's it's
contained maintain ERS from these
projects that got together to got
together to create a standard amongst
the r the ray libraries in high so that
was the goal it's a very ambitious goal
because all the r libraries have
different functionality and so
after a year or so they created um the
standard um this is what the standard
incorporates um it's focus on numerical
computation so numbers um and um things
like adding adding arrays um doing like
simple math um competion like means and
medians creating arrays things you think
about when you deal with arrays um
broadcasting too from napai um the
things that doesn't that are not in
scope are things that are not numerical
IO it's on this part of the slide um
thing to keep in um to keep track of is
that the types of like dat times and
strings are not part of the spec so if
you use ND arrays with strings which I
don't think you should because they're
objects um you can't use the array
standard
so there and on the link has a full spec
it's just a big D spec sheet of all the
things that in the
specification now there's also
extensions to a r API
um there's extension Ser API there's
linear algebra and there's for
transforms all most of this almost
everyone does line algebra and that is
what is important for machine learning
we need line algebra for cycle learning
machine learning so this is um the thing
we uh that's what we need and like all
Pi Pi 2 pi they all have algebra so it
all it all works but these are optional
extensions so
libr already usually include them
because if if you have a library usually
you have anyra that's like
given um so here's what the vision is
and what the code like the when the
thing was developed this is what the
vision um supposed to be um you have
some lpai code you see that it's calling
numpy like NP that something and then
it's um doing some
computation and the vision is well um if
you want to write API code well instead
of just calling n directly we grab the
name space from the uh the the array
object that the user passed in grab the
module and then from the
module call the the functionality so for
p p case XP is just
torch and and then if for Q Pi's case it
would be Q pi and so forth and so on
this is the division this is
division they could precursive that when
say this is division but um if there is
uh so for during the initial release of
this in
2022 um it supported NP and Q Pi but not
the ND arrays that you know and love
like Q like n um np. ND array or Qi that
they NP and Qi created their own name
space with a different array object to
support the array API that means use if
you want user to use this they have to
know about this other object and that
was that was I didn't like
that why like there's so many objects
why I have another one and it's it's
kind of clunky and we're look we see
that we look at that in cold um but yeah
so it supported it created a new names
space there's a reason for that the
reason was that the ND array Nam space
doesn't conform to the spe so they
creating a new one is easier but it's
also harder for users because there's
another object you to think about um so
do like bring this point home this is
what array High um um support look like
in like learn
1.2
in in um 2002
20122 um so it's still the same API you
have some way to enable it like with in
this case a global dispatch with a
global configuration and users usually
have their qy Rays like this is a
standard ND array for a q for for a q
array but then they also had to do like
a transformation of that object to the
conformant array so like you see that I
orded XP from the the qy. API name space
I also had to a users will also have to
do this conversion too to use this
which is not the best future API and
that's why I didn't talk about this in
2022 it's like a a secret feature
because this is a I I thought this API
was
horrible and I think it is like
who
so so it yeah 2022 this is what it
looked like
but in a collaboration between meta and
Quan sites um there is a there is
um quanite developed a new package that
libraries can use to make this a little
better and the library is called arayi
Compact and what this does is extends
array thei standard to the main name
space so you don't have to go through
this transformation back and forth
between the this this other name space
and to the ND object so um so that's
what every API compat is it supports NP
q and P torch um
there's in P currently so that means um
the way you use it is what the vision
like the the
vision what my vision had like the C
before with the with the vision is
exactly the way you use array P compa so
you import array namespace from the
Library which is a pure python Library
there's no compiled functions it's just
it's Z it's very easy to install um and
it's it's it does Inc Division and it
works with ND arrays it works with QP ND
arrays works with P sensors it also
works with these other things the the
other Nam space because but I don't
think people should use them on the over
here so main users should be would be
all already using these other these
normal ND arrays and then you pass it to
um your library that calls array name
space and it should it will just work
with some challenges which we'll talk
about in the next
part so um stepping back um array Pi
supports this is what it looks like this
is what the slide I showed you it's you
don't have to go to this this exchange
between two different objects it just
works with the origal know um in this
case tensor the py tensor and this just
works
so that
is uh AR
R so with that context I hope you all
motivated to write your code using the r
gu standard like like how many of you
have maintained nump code right now like
you have NP code or P code and
you deal with it so yeah so and you and
you work with it and you did job but and
if you want to write in a r API this is
the challenges you will face when
migrating a subset of them not all of
them but some things I want to
highlight so overarching the challenges
are um there's API differences between
if you use NP Cod there's API
differences between the NP Cod side and
a API standard there's semantic
differences which means things that work
in nonp if you change nothing
it would not work in the API and we'll
see what those some of those things and
then compile code which is a very big um
uh item uh this is how many people have
compiled code in their library or in
their packages compile code okay so
we're going to have a fun time in that
section for you just for
you so API
differences okay
okay API differences so nump um nump um
for the API most methods are on the
module or in the module what that means
is let's say you have code where you
call this Y is a ND array and call sum
just does what it does it does what it
says if you want to migrate this to
Ari you have to there's no there's not
many methods on the on the object you
have to actually go to name space and
grab the the the the operation it's not
that bad it's not that bad this is this
is fine everyone do this um the the the
where it gets a little you a little
Annoying is when you have ch when you
chain them like uh if you're doing this
this is what it looks like it looks kind
of nice you're just taking the mean and
then you're doing a bullying operation
and then you calling any if you want to
migrate this to your API you have to
kind of Nest them it's it's not not too
bad but you can tell if you have keep on
if you keep on expanding this it kind of
gets a little gar like it doesn't look
as nice but it's it works in Aria how
that's what you have to
do um another thing is that um Matrix
motation uh if you use mp. dot that
doesn't exist in AI because um
historically MP do does too much MP that
do does like if you have one ND um ND
aray and 2dr it does something else and
have two 1D arrays it does has it does
too much so in ARR Pi there's no dots
there's a there's just macation so this
is this is also a simple one because so
in this case it restricts the dimension
to be what you have to be dation
location it doesn't do um all the
complex complexity and dots so these are
these are the simple ones these are not
too bad
um unique is um mp. unique is very
commonly used in cycle learn because
when you pass a uh for classifier when
you class when you pass classes into
cycle learn it needs to know what the
classes are so it called np. unique and
for nump this MP unique has um it gives
you the uniques and it has many
different of these return
parameters and which gives you different
depending on what you set it gives you
different return options
a RI doesn't have unique it has a
different um word for them like a
different method name and this is a it's
a common pattern like every every have
sometimes have different um method names
and nump so you have to transition it
does it also doesn't have these return
keywords because um if I put on my
software design hat having a keyboard
argument that changes the number of
arguments of your function your best
return your function returns it's a bad
pattern so API doesn't have that either
so you need to call Un need counts so
differences in
API this is a this is a this we run into
this like learn where there are some
some P functions that are useful that
are not in AR API
like n Max like this is this doesn't
seem too bad it's just it's the max but
ignoring the N this does not not exists
in already pi and the way we worked
around this
in in uh Pyle learn is
that we uh Define our own on the array G
so if it's a nump array we well we just
call
numpy um if it's a a very Pi standard
array we uh we Define our own based on
the standard and that's what we have to
do
um there is an issue open on RI they're
very receptive of this where you could
if if there's something you need open an
issue and they consider put into the
standard this has happened before we we
needed something we open an issue they
put in the standard it's great so
they're very receptive to adding new
things to the
standard um um this is one of them uh so
in this case I'm doing integer indexing
I'm just indexing some um RS um 0
one doesn't work in a rare API you need
to use a method integer indexing with
multiple
index a list doesn't work you have to
call xp. take this is very common in
machine learning where you're like
you're shuffling things or you're
sampling things so we needed this and so
they added into standard in 2022 that's
12 not through um in index thing but
using a operation which is okay it's
not that's hard to detect because
sometimes it's
program right you don't pass in literals
you may pass in a variable that that so
it's not that easy to oh true change so
if you do this in it will error so you
have to pass in AR compatible arrays and
it error and then you can detect it but
it's really it is kind of it was kind of
it's
iffy but the thing is M XA take it also
exist in NP so it's it's n take Al it
already exist in NP so if it would just
be compatible with nump anyway so it's
fine it's it's okay um the other part is
that this part where you to think um a
API standard likes to work with
arrays so you can't use a python list
anymore you have to use an
array right
so okay getting you know more and more
challenging as I go you
know so um we keep going multiple
Dimension um so this is a 2d anday I
just want the index one row right so I
just do this is fine it just looks fine
doesn't work in a RI but it's not too
bad
is um it give you an index there and
it'll give you and where you have to
specify the other dimensions so it
doesn't assume that you want um all of
everything everything else you have to
put in this um colon to say I want the
rest of the
columns all right
right a lot of little nits here who who
came up with that that is so assume I'll
answer the question
afterwards
but it's
yeah um who who uses Rand number
generation like a thing well doesn't
exist
in so um you know Rand number Generation
Um what cyc learn does because like like
a lot of machine learning you
instantiate a model random numbers it's
a very standard thing to do what we end
up doing is we use numpy as random
number generation and then we um
converted it into the r it works
um it works
okay this one is um who who cares who
knows about order for and okay this is
for you um order is a thing um C ordered
means that when you so for this is a 2d
array C ordered means that if you
Traverse the array left to right in
memory the data is right next to each
other
so yeah and um if you f order means that
if youever the and the array up and down
the data is right next to each other so
that means that if you writing nonp code
and you want to sometimes optimize more
for it let's say you're summing over the
going up and down and summing over the
the columns going up and down that means
that a f order array is faster because
the the DAT right next to each other so
the CPU doesn't have to
jump um so this is a common thing to do
like this we do inyc learn sometimes
because you know we're machine learning
library want to be
proficient order doesn't exist in a r
standard so there's no hack around this
there's nothing you can't do this so all
right so there's no notion of order
in okay so I don't have a good work
around for this okay I went a few of the
differences that I think are important
there's a lot there there's a great um
page about this on nump dots I'm if you
care about if you want to look at the
difference between the r API standard
and numpy this is what you have to look
into it's a really long page it's a um
it's it's very well written it gives you
all the
differences oh okay next semantic
differences um which is um things that
work in work in N High code that doesn't
work in API code if you change nothing
so in this case I'm adding a uh an ND
array that's integers and um and the
array that exp loods oh this means um so
n will upcast the integer to a float and
it has them correct has them up a API
will error it will not upcast for you I
I think this is better I for this case I
think this is a better like in principle
I think this is better like not
upcasting it's upcasting lead to many
performance things because you have the
memory copy when you upcast so I think
this is a better default but it's still
it's a little
annoying so the work around is you have
to um do the cast you have to explicitly
cast up before you can add to N I think
this is by default but you still have to
go through this turtle um also um who
it's when you use npay it's very common
to use it with python scalers because
you're in Python
Lan um so this this also applies to
python scalar so this is a nay that's
integers I add it to a python float this
is fine in n typ eror in Array desat
because no outcasting so the same work
around the same working around you have
to um type your ND array for
work um one one more thing is array
creation so when you work with array
Library you very often create arrays um
so in the top I create a ND array with
lens space um lmb space Also exists in
our API this one's not it's not too bad
it's
well for the ri standard you have to be
careful about ping things on the device
that your user pass so like if you
usually pass in a Cuda Cuda array back
Cuda device you have to make sure all
the new arrays you form are also backed
by Cuda because you want to operate
between them like you need a Cuda AR to
work on a Cuda AR R so you have to pay
attention to when you create these array
um create new arrays make sure they
create the device that's so another so
this is standard this makes sense so
that's for
device okay
so compile code this is a big
one
[Music]
um this
is um compal code exists in many places
in cyc learn they're in the far the Tre
algorithm the gring algorithm the line
models line models uses scipi which uses
CI that optimize which uses four chain
code which is compiled
so so this comp everywhere and array
standard is a
python um specification so it doesn't
touch compound code
so there we've been thinking about
workaround for
this um U one of the one the solution
that works now and that scipi has
implemented is that they can that that
only works on um CPU arrays is they
convert from nump and back convert to NP
and then go back so what this looks like
is let's say you do some ARR Pi code
above um convert your array back to
numpy and then have your compile code
that works with numpy work on that and
then
afterwards convert back to the array GI
like
object it works um it only works with
the CP with CPU because you know the C
only works on CPU so that's um that um
it's so s is currently doing this
now um there's like been a attempts to
do this better because we don't we want
to dispatch the compile code that is not
just your CPU you want to this actually
like GPU compile code too somehow
there's been attempts on this scipi has
urray
which um has not panned out um simply
put um py learn is experimenting with
something called plugins which is not in
main yet but it's we we talk a little
bit about it so this is like and um the
thing in discussions with CPI they they
look like they're thinking about doing
this one which we'll talk about quickly
in the next few minutes so dispatching
with let's say plugins it's what it say
well um a third party Library may be
developed by someone else could create a
plugin and to write the Cuda kernel and
then we dispatch to it that's all it
does um this a VPI is still important in
this use case because it's very
frequently that you do compile code
somewhere you do like normal python
operations before um before your compile
code and then you do some normal python
operations after so you only dispatch
for the compile code and API has a
standard for doing things that are in
python
L next the array Library spec specific
code um the standard
has uh the standard has a specific set
of um operations but many of the r
libraries Implement more than the
standard and it's shared them between
them so for example Earth is a um it's a
integral and um you can
you
can um you could dispatch to n Pi QP Pi
torch and to Earth so that's that's
something that scipi think about doing
so it's a library specific
code so those are challenges um there's
a lot of them
why now there's um a smaller API because
it is smaller um it's portable and
performance yeah yeah so this is these
are the the main reasons whyp standard
was adopted it was for this graph um to
make this work um scii is also adopting
this there that they use a um a uh
experiment uh environment
flag these are the things that supported
scipi now so scipi and cyar is slowly
adopting this now um you can read more
if you're a user try out the feature and
C learn if you're Li
author we welcome to try out R standard
you can open issue on their um if you
have a if you have a function that you
need you can open an issue on their um
issue tracker and everything here is
available on my GitHub account public uh
and thank you everyone for listening to
The
[Applause]
Talk